[Musique]
écoute celui-là tu vas rire certains
avancent qu'à l'instar des araignées
mâles par coeur possède le pouvoir
d'hypnotiser les femelles
et si on restait sur ce toit toute la
journée c'est trop la folie en bas
tu es mystérieux ce sont les drones ces
drones ce sont les vôtres
quelque part tu te sens pas un peu
soulagé qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
maintenant que tout le monde est au
courant t'es plus obligé de te cacher ni
de mentir pour info j'ai jamais voulu te
mentir mais c'est pas simple d'expliquer
à quelqu'un qu'on est Spider-Man
aujourd'hui le monde entier est au
courant et dans cette histoire il y a
pas que moi beaucoup de gens souffrent
je dois trouver un moyen d'arranger tout
ça
alors Peter que me vaut ce plaisir
désolé de vous déranger monsieur voyons
on a sauvé la moitié de l'univers
ensemble je crois qu'on a dépassé le
stade des monsieur ok Steven
ça fait bizarre mais tu as le droit
quand Mysterio a révélé mon identité sa
foutu un gros bordel dans ma vie
je me demandais si vous pouviez faire un
truc pour annuler tout ça
strange ne vous servez pas de cette
magie c'est trop dangereux très bien je
n'en ferai rien
bientôt le monde entier aura oublié que
Peter Parker et Spider-Man le monde
entier
on peut faire des exceptions le
sortilège ne permet aucune exception
alors MJ va oublier toutes les choses
qu'on a vécues interfère pas avec le
sortilège oh purée n'était mon meilleur
pote oh il m'a tente mais bon
mais c'est quoi là
nous avons altéré la stabilité de
l'espace-temps
nos connaissances sur le fonctionnement
du multivers sont affreusement limités
le problème c'est que tu essaies de
vivre de vie en même temps
il persiste à le faire ça risque de
devenir dangereux
veille à faire les bons choix par cœur
salut Peter
[Musique]